[Musique]
[Musique] [Applaudissements]
vous êtes directeur du patrimoine mondial de
l'UNESCO et vous avez eu une phrase un jour que
je trouve absolument magnifique vous avez dit je
ne suis pas là pour préserver des pierres parce
que ce qu'on préserve c'est la vie qu'est-ce que
vous voulez dire par là c'est pour expliquer que
quand on parle du patrimoine on parle de ce qui
définit toutes les sociétés humanité les sociétés
tout ce qui est vivant tout ce qui nous permet
de nous identifier que nous sommes des humains
que nous appartenons à différentes régions du
monde et que nous avons toute une histoire et
c'est cette diversité culturelle qui se reflète à
travers le patrimoine et donc quand on préserve le
patrimoine non seulement on préserve toute cette
identité toute cette diversité plurielle de ce
qui constitue le monde mais on préserve aussi
la vie parce que c'est cette vie là qui fait
que nous pouvons nous mélanger nous pouvons nous
comprendre et dont nous pouvons promouvoir la paix
vous prononcer le mot de paix vous avez absolument
besoin du multilatéralisme c'est à dire que il
faut que tout le monde soit autour de la table
cela c'est essentiel justement pour préserver ces
pierres et pour faire en sorte que la vie perdure
bah oui parce que le multilatéralisme permet de
mettre des choses en commun et de se donner
des missions précises qui permettent de régler
des questions fondamentales dans les domaines
dans le domaine de l'éducation le domaine de la
culture en particulier et c'est aussi pourquoi le
multilatéralisme ici est important aussi pour la
préservation du patrimoine mondial alors quand on
pense au patrimoine on pense beaucoup pierre au
monument mais c'est aussi des paysages c'est des
paysages c'est pour ça que j'ai l'habitude de dire
que à la fois les monuments sont importants comme
Notre Dame c'est à Paris ou la Tour Eiffel ou mais
ce qui est aussi important c'est ce qui permet
de comprendre comment les différentes sociétés
occupent un territoire et à travers ce
territoire là le transforme et ce qui permet
qu'il s'identifie à celui et préserve leur culture
donc c'est pour ça que les paysages culturels sont
très importants et ça façonne la culture de chaque
peuple non seulement ça la façon mais ça permet de
mieux la comprendre et de la partager c'est aussi
ce qui nous intéresse le plus c'est pas simplement
de se focaliser à comprendre comment on la façon
mais surtout à partager et à partager surtout les
messages qui sont très importants qui sont en fait
les messages d'universalité pourquoi il y a si peu
de sites de monuments de bien culturels qui soient
inscrit au patrimoine mondial et qui proviennent
d'Afrique alors si j'avais une réponse très claire
je pense que on aurait déjà réglé la question mais
nous avons essayé de comprendre ce qui s'est passé
depuis que les premiers sites ont été inscrits sur
la Liste du patrimoine mondial il faut savoir que
c'était comment ça en 1978 d'accord parce que la
Convention du patrimoine mondial qui permettait
justement l'inscription des sites au patrimoine
mondial a étant adopté en 1972 donc 6 ans après
ce principe de de liste du patrimoine mondial a
commencé à accueillir des premiers sites il faut
dire que dans ces premiers sites il y avait des
sites africains alors par la suite cela peut
s'expliquer par la nécessité d'abord de mettre
en place un nombre de politiques pour mieux les
identifier ces sites en Afrique et il faut dire
que à ce moment là certaines régions comme comme
l'Europe en elle commençait à proposer un peu plus
de sites parce que les professionnels étaient
déjà formés des politiques de préservation du
patrimoine avait déjà été mise en place alors que
dans certaines régions se représentées aujourd'hui
ce processus commençait et voilà un peu comment
l'écart s'est creusé et c'est cet écart là qu'il
faudrait aujourd'hui essayer de rattraper et
réduire combien y a-t-il de sites inscrits au
Patrimoine mondial qui sont Africains si on
parle de l'Afrique continentale avec Maurice
et Madagascar en comptant aussi la partie nord
de l'Afrique on est à un total de 139 sites qui
sont inscrits sur la liste sur conviviale sur un
total de 1157 il y a un retard terrible et alors
quand on prend que l'Afrique subsaharienne
il y en a que 98 donc les carrés quand même
important et lorsqu'on sait qu'en même temps
cet Afrique regorge d'une incroyable richesse de
patrimoine qui mériterait un jour de rejoindre la
liste du patrimoine mondial on se rend compte que
il faut y accorder une attention particulière
aujourd'hui pour aider les pays africains à
mettre en place les politiques à former des
professionnels qui pourraient non seulement les
gérer non seulement les préserver mais aussi
préparer les dossiers pour les proposer pour
candidatures au patrimoine mondial alors je crois
savoir qu'il y a une école qui s'est constituée
au Bénin une école du patrimoine africain non et
l'école du patrimoine africain existe d'ailleurs
c'est une excellente chose aujourd'hui que des
profits de temps je crois oui puisse aller se
former plus se former en Afrique et c'est au Bénin
que ça se passe il faut encourager c'est au Bénin
aujourd'hui cette école il y en a une autre qui
a qui au Kenya pour les pays anglophones mais
il faudrait encourager le développement de de ce
type d'institutions de formation professionnelle
pour former de plus en plus de professionnels
pas simplement pour le patrimoine matériel ou
matériel aussi pour la préservation des musées
pour la lutte contre le trafic et les sites sont
importantes alors la préservation des identités
deux choses en termes de bien culturels et de
monuments qu'est-ce qu'on peut recenser qu'est-ce
qu'il y a il y a les pyramides de Gizeh j'imagine
il y a la prison de Robin Island qu'est-ce qu'il y
a d'autres on avait cité certaines qui sont assez
extraordinaires que l'on ne peut pas visiter mais
aussi quand on regarde le reste de l'Afrique si on
va par exemple au Sénégal on va on va aller voir
l'île de Gorée ou l'ancienne ville de Saint-Louis
et un peu plus loin la petite un petit pays
comme la Gambie qui est à l'île de James is
ce qu'on appelle l'île de Kunta Kinte qui est
assez importante et si on traverse une partie
de l'Afrique et qu'on se retrouve en Afrique de
l'Est en Éthiopie vous avez des sites importants
comme la libella on peut descendre même un peu
plus bas en Afrique austral au même aux Zimbabwe
par exemple donc vous avez le Grand Zimbabwe
et alors je peux vous en citer beaucoup mais
qui sont pas simplement des monuments mais
qui sont aussi qui sont aussi des sites et
des paysages comme par exemple le Kilimanjaro
ou encore un peu au Kenya des forêts sacrées
mais incroyables les forêts de musique kenda par
exemple qu'on ne qu'on ne connaît pas mais qu'il
faudrait de plus en plus connaître ou alors les
paysages culturels de conso aussi en Éthiopie il
y a aussi des des forêts préservées qui sont
qui sont très très importantes en République
démocratique du Congo par exemple ou même à
Madagascar avec des des forêts primaires très
importantes il y a beaucoup de sites aussi il faut
le dire qui sont menacés par la guerre qui sont
menacés par le réchauffement climatique comment
préserver tout ça et notamment vous avez beaucoup
peuvré vous-même d'ailleurs personnellement à
ton bouquetou au Mali ou pays en guerre pour
préserver et bien les manuscrits de Tombouctou ou
les mausolées aussi de tout comment vous avez fait
pour essayer de préserver tout ça de la guerre et
des ravages des attaques djihadistes d'abord vous
avez raison de dire aujourd'hui que le patrimoine
mondial est de plus en plus menacé par certains
dangers comme les guerres les conflits armés qui
qui font que le patrimoine est détruit et ça c'est
quelque chose de terrible et l'une des grandes
particularité du concept de patrimoine mondial
c'est que quand le patrimoine est en danger et
détruit la communauté internationale se mobilise
pour essayer de préserver ce patrimoine parce
qu'il n'est pas simplement important pour les
pays en question mais il est un patrimoine de
l'humanité donc il est important parce qu'il
raconte l'histoire de notre humanité c'est ce
qui s'est passé effectivement avec Tombouctou une
ville [Musique] millénaire comme comme celle-là où
il y a eu une université au 15e siècle ou beaucoup
d'érudits à prendre venez apprendre et où il y
a eu un centre intellectuel très important avec
une production non seulement de de manuscrits dont
certains sont scientifiques assez important et qui
en arabe et aussi des centres un centre religieux
et c'est pour ça que les mausolées auxquels les
populations étaient attachées et était important
à préserver parce que sans ces mausolée c'est ça
allait être la complète déstructuration d'une
vie sociale qui a été préservée depuis le 11e
siècle ouais jusqu'à ce jour extraordinaire
et ça c'est important et à côté de ce danger
qui la destruction du patrimoine en période de
confirmé on a aussi ce phénomène du changement
climatique pour les manuscrits de Tombouctou
ils ont été transportés en voiture comment ça
s'est passé la nuit comment vous avez fait pour
échapper justement à la menace djihadiste alors
d'abord ça a été une initiative incroyable
des communautés de Tombouctou des villageois
en fait non mais de ces groupes qui étaient
à Tombouctou et qui préservait eux-mêmes déjà
de leur famille d'accord et qui se sont
rendus compte que cette trésor qu'ils avaient
hérité de leur famille qui montrait que leurs
ancêtres avaient été des des grands intellectuels
qui avaient contribué au développement
de cette ville à son rayonnement n'avait
pas envie de les perdre et il nous disait
toujours que perdre les manuscrits et les
mausolées c'était un peu comme perdre leurs deux
poumons donc perdre la vie et au péril de leur vie
ces communautés ont sorties ces manuscrits de
la ville de la ville pour aller les cacher à
Bamako un peu plus elles ont sorti près de 400 000
manuscrits de temps au péril de leur ville c'était
quelquefois à dos d'âne pour sortir les pirogues
jusqu'à Mopti et après continuer par la voiture
par la route voilà heureusement beaucoup d'entre
de ces manuscrits ont été préservés mais on en a
quand même perdu plus de 4000 manuscrits parce
que certains ont été brûlés et certains étaient
volés est-ce que c'est une région c'est elle qui
est très menacée et beaucoup de pays en Afrique
malheureusement par l'islamisme est-ce que le
patrimoine peut être menacé par justement une
idéologie qui cherche à remettre en question la
culture ancestrale que souvent beaucoup de pays
c'est ce que nous avons observé à Tombouctou
une communauté qui vivait depuis 9 siècles avec
une pratique de l'Islam qui est l'Islam Sophie
et qui de toute façon avait cette habitude
là à la fois de pratiquer l'islam mais aussi
de rendre hommage à leurs ancêtres qui avaient
contribué au développement de la ville et avec une
occupation de Tombouctou à partir de 2012 par des
groupes armés et des groupes extrémistes amenant
une autre idéologie ils ont cherché à stopper
cette continuité de pratiques culturelles et de
et religieuse et pour cela il fallait détruire
le patrimoine comme étant ce symbole important
qui était important pour ces communautés et
grâce aux habitants ils n'ont pas réussi à
le faire ils ont quand même détruit les
mausolées que l'UNESCO a reconstruit moi
j'ai eu une chance énorme et le privilège
d'être celui que l'UNESCO a chargé de cette
œuvre de mener cette stratégie de reconstruction
avec nos partenaires mais mais ce qui est surtout
important nous avons reconstruit les mausolées
de Tombouctou avec la pluie des communautés qui
voulaient que leur majolais soit préservé
semble aussi aller un peu plus loin c'est
que nous avons remis à jour toutes les traditions
de maintien de d'entretien de ces mausolées là
alors tout à l'heure je parlais de la prison de
Robin Island c'est une prison qui a été fréquentée
par un homme qui est une figure de l'Afrique pour
toujours qui est Nelson Mandela parce que il était
interdé dans cette ce centre pénitentiaire au
bail Island c'est une île au large de l'Afrique
du Sud donc il y a été interné pendant 17 ans une
partie de sa détention vous avez eu ce privilège
sans doute de connaître cet homme parce que
vous êtes architecte et que à l'époque vous
l'avez connu vous étiez en charge d'un programme
immobilier en Afrique du Sud à Cape Town je crois
racontez-nous comment ça s'est passé déjà c'est
toujours avec beaucoup d'émotions que je me ré
mémorce ce moment important qui vous transforme
en tant qu'homme Nelson Mandela est une icône de
notre monde et j'avais souhaité aller en Afrique
du Sud comme un jeune architecte intéressée pour
aider la construction de logements sociaux à très
bas prix et j'avais envie d'aller contribuer à ce
programme de reconstruction de développement que
le président Nelson Mandela avait lancé quand
il a été élu pour reconstruire pour donner des
logements à un million de personnes en Afrique
et nous avons avec l'organisation que je
représentais de relation cratère qui est basée à
l'école d'architecture de Grenoble nous avons mis
en place une stratégie qui n'était pas simplement
de construire des logements mais qui était de
dire que nous allions former des personnes qui
avaient vécu la parfaite qui n'avait pas eu
cette opportunité d'aller à l'école d'accord
à des métiers de construction et ensuite de les
accompagner pour qu'ils deviennent eux-mêmes des
entrepreneurs pour construire d'autres logements
que nous avions en place et c'était une une
idée qui a beaucoup beaucoup plus au président
Nelson Mandela qui l'a eu envie de venir voir
ce Camerounais qui habitait à islandone
pour venir aider les Sud-Africains c'était
vous et c'était moi et il est venu et nous
avons visité je lui ai montré un peu tout
ce que nous faisions dans un tramship donc un
chip c'est un centre urbain réservé aux Noirs
il était venu pour 15 minutes et finalement
avec tout ce que je lui montrais et que les
explications je lui donnais il a envie eu envie de
passer encore plus de temps et nous sommes restés
deux heures ensemble à boire du thé d'accord
parler d'autre chose et ces moments où vous
marre parce que il a été par des mots de très très
encourageant en montrant effectivement que ce que
nous faisions était important pour le peuple
d'Afrique du Sud et que lui il en est vraiment
été non seulement très content mais fier que ce
soit un Africain qui fait ça qui viennent aider
d'autres Africains en Afrique du Sud quand vous
passez du temps avec un homme que vous n'espérez
pas connaître ou rencontrer un jour et qui vous
montre finalement qu'il est aussi simple que vous
et moi et par ces attitudes et l'attention qu'il
vous porte à ce moment-là vous donne une façon
de regarder la vie et ça vous transforme dans
la manière dont vous devez servir les autres
c'est ce qui m'a beaucoup apporté et qui m'a amené
certainement à poursuivre ma carrière avec Nelson
Mandela comme un grand modèle aujourd'hui vous
êtes directeur du patrimoine mondial de l'UNESCO
d'ailleurs vous devez vous réjouir de voir
que les États-Unis reviennent à l'intérieur de
l'organisation Louisienne mais avant ça vous
avez été chargé aussi de ce qu'on a appelé
l'épisode de la qui est pas terminé qui est loin
d'être terminée des restitutions d'oeuvres d'art
africaines qui ont pu être pillés ou exporter
en Europe ou en Occident ou ailleurs là on voit
d'ailleurs les les statues d'Abomey au Bénin qui
ont été restitués en 2021 si je ne m'abuse est-ce
que cette restitution pour vous est une bonne
chose alors la restitution est une bonne chose
en 1978 le l'ancien Directeur général de l'UNESCO
dans le détail générale de l'époque Amadou matambo
qui était sénégalais qui était sénégalais avait
lancé un appel pour la restitution des biens
culturels au pays et à ceux qui les avaient créés
ça veut donc dire que il s'agissait à ce moment-là
d'amener les États à coopérer pour que les pays
qui souhaitaient nos retours et la restitution
des oeuvres importantes pour leur peuple puisse
dialoguer afin que ce retour soit possible donc
la restitution quand elle aboutit est une très
bonne chose est-ce que ça répare le passé qui est
un passé colonial qui est un passé parfois très
douloureux alors l'idée de la restitution est pas
de réparer le passé l'idée de la restitution est
d'aider et de construire l'avenir et de renforcer
la coopération j'ai toujours pour habitude de dire
que il s'agit pas que les pays africains disent
vous avez pris des objets ben rendez les nous il
s'agit de dire contribuer à notre nouvelle manière
de préparer l'avenir de nos pays parce que
c'est une façon de se construire c'est une
façon de renforcer la coopération et bien sûr
pas de se construire parce que il y a pas que
les États africains qui demandent le retour de
phénomène si on américaine oui c'est ça donc
c'est cette coopération qui est aujourd'hui
importante et d'ailleurs les professionnels
africains sont très claires là dessus il ne
demande pas le retour de tous les objets il
demande le retour des objets qui leur sont les
plus significatifs pour aider non seulement à la
recherche pour aider à l'éducation de ceux qui ne
peuvent pas venir les regarder ces gens aussi mais
aussi au tourisme au développement économique il
y a beaucoup de trafic d'oeuvres d'art en Afrique
le trafic illicite est un phénomène mondial
alors il y a le trafic illicite bien culturels
partout parce que c'est c'est un commerce c'est
un commerce illicite et qui rapporte mais c'est
en période de conflit et de guerre c'est encore
beaucoup plus grave on a vu le trafic les sites
des biens culturels au nord du Mali des biens qui
sont partis ont des sites archéologiques qui sont
pillés en Libye aussi sans doute on en a vu aussi
en Libye on a vu un Irak et en Syrie et dans tous
ses biens se retrouvent sur le marché à des prix
exorbitants et il faut lutter contre ce trafic
illicite parce que ce n'est pas que des objets
qui partent mais c'est une partie importante de
l'histoire de de ces pays qui disparaît il faut
qu'on continue de lutter contre ce phénomène et
ce fléau terrible que le trafiqué décide de bien
culturels et effectivement il y en a en Afrique
mais il y en a partout dans le monde entier alors
deux petites questions pour terminer quel est
votre votre monument votre site africain préféré
alors évidemment j'ai toujours été impressionné
par tous les sites africains mais il y en a un
qui m'a le plus marqué c'est celui où j'ai passé
beaucoup de temps à reconstruire c'est Tombouctou
oui les mausolée pas simplement et même la ville
avec ses trois grandes mosquées et la mosquée de
jingare qui a été construite en 1325 et qui est
toujours aujourd'hui une des plus grandes mosquées
construite en terre et qui est incroyablement
belle à l'intérieur comme à l'extérieur parce
que c'est un architecte andalou entre 125 qui
était venu avec Kankan Moussa pour la pour la
construire j'ai aussi des sites qui qui sont
des sites qui nous rappellent à quel point le
l'Afrique c'est une culture qui est à la femme
matérielle et immatérielle et c'est les forêts
sacrées de michikanda dont j'ai parlé ou sur
un site comme celui-là quand on le visite on
rentre dans ce site en enlevant ses chaussures
on se reconnecte au lieu d'une forêt à la terre
dans la forêt sacrée de michikanda au Kenya a
pas très loin de mon bassin c'est-à-dire sur la
côte de l'Océan Indien et je pourrais vous parler
de sabot et je vois exactement je pourrais vous
parler de d'autres sites aussi qui sont qui sont
importants je sais que je vais faire peut-être
déjà l'eau incitant c'est encore un alors ces
deux sites mais vous avez aussi l'île de Nelson
mandeline qui vous marque quand vous la visiter
et si vous aviez un écrivain qui vous inspire
africain ça serait lequel alors je pense à un
écrivain qui est aujourd'hui disparu qui a écrit
un livre qui s'appelle le soleil des indépendances
Amadou Kourouma alors ce livre il est un écrivain
ivoirien ivoirien ce livre il m'a marqué
quand je l'ai lu parce que c'est un livre
d'abord qui est écrit dans les années 70 et
qui qui vous fait un peu cette on va choisir
cette peinture de l'Afrique des indépendances
et comment un prince malinké Pharma essaye de
s'adapter à cette nouvelle vie et confronté
un peu à ses propres contradictions et c'est
intéressant parce qu'en même temps il y a
des des questions politiques qui arrivent
qui sont toutes nouvelles mais il y a aussi
le nécessaire besoin de retrouver un peu
toute son histoire qui était une histoire
culturelle et puis c'est traditions et je
crois que beaucoup de d'entre nous sont un
peu dans cette dualité et ce livre en fait
ce roman en particulier est toujours dit
encore un roman qui va se dire présent et
contemporain d'actualité et d'actualité et j'aime
beaucoup ce que Amadou Kourouma a écrit dans le
soleil des indépendances merci Lazare et lindou
assombo merci plaisir merci beaucoup [Musique]